ahora vamos a continuar nuestra
discusión sobre el mercado de factores y
vamos a ir más allá de solamente pensar
en el trabajo como un solo factor de
hecho en este vídeo vamos a empezar a
pensar en el capital que como sabes es
otro de los factores de producción así
que como un pequeño repaso ya hemos
analizado desde la perspectiva de una
empresa cuál es la cantidad racional de
trabajo que se debe contratar y debemos
basarnos en el ingreso marginal producto
del trabajo y en el costo marginal
factor del trabajo así que en el eje
horizontal tenemos la cantidad de
trabajo que contratará la empresa y en
el eje vertical tenemos el salario que
puedes ver como el precio del trabajo
y como ya hemos visto varias veces
tienes una curva de ingreso marginal
producto con pendiente descendiente y
quiero ser muy específico que este es el
ingreso marginal producto del trabajo
y después tenemos la curva del costo
marginal factor del trabajo y estamos
suponiendo que esta empresa está en
competencia perfecta en el mercado del
trabajo entonces tiene que pagar el
salario del mercado es por eso que
tenemos una recta horizontal por aquí
esta es la curva del costo marginal
factor del trabajo
y ya lo hemos hablado muchas veces es
razonable para la empresa seguir
contratando siempre que el ingreso
marginal producto del trabajo es decir
siempre que el ingreso adicional que la
empresa obtenga de cada una de estas
personas o de cada una de estas unidades
de trabajo que ellos contraten sea mayor
que el costo adicional de cada una de
estas unidades de trabajo es decir
seguir contratando hasta que estas dos
rectas inter sequen así que será
racional contratar esta cantidad de
trabajo es decir esta es la cantidad de
trabajo para la empresa y le pondré una
estrella para etiquetar esta es la
cantidad de trabajo y podemos dibujar
algo similar para el capital
todo esto lo pensamos para este insumo
estamos pensando en el trabajo pero
podemos hacer algo similar para el
capital o podríamos hacerlo para la
tierra entonces tengo otra gráfica para
la empresa pero nos vamos a aplicar en
él
puedes ver que tendremos ejes análogos
en el eje horizontal puedes observar que
tenemos la cantidad pero esta vez no es
de trabajo será de capital y en el eje
vertical tenemos el precio del capital
podemos verlo como la renta o alquiler y
se puede pensar por ejemplo en alquilar
algún tipo de maquinaria además tendrás
tu ingreso marginal producto del capital
puedes ver que tiene rendimientos
decrecientes es por eso que tiene una
pendiente decreciente así que este es
nuestro ingreso marginal producto del
capital y típicamente se usa acá para
capital para que la cee no se confunda
con otras cosas y luego tenemos nuestro
costo marginal factor y una vez más
supongamos que estamos en una
competencia perfecta para el mercado de
capital así que tenemos que pagar
cualquiera que sea el precio del mercado
para alquilar o rentar este tipo de
capital por lo tanto esto es el costo
marginal factor
del capital y una vez más tiene sentido
traer más y más y más capital siempre
que el ingreso adicional que obtengamos
de esas unidades extras de capital sea
mayor que el costo de cada una de esas
unidades extras de capital entonces por
aquí es racional para la empresa que se
produzca esta cantidad si sólo pensamos
en la dimensión del capital así que esto
será la cantidad de capital que emplea
la empresa
ahora una pregunta interesante que
seguramente cruza por tu mente es si la
empresa tiene una cierta cantidad de
recursos limitados entonces cómo elegir
qué cantidad de utilizar de trabajo
contra qué cantidad de utilizar de
capital
ellos no sólo piensan en cuántos insumos
requieren de cada uno de estos dos
factores además tienen que pensar en
relación de uno con el otro y para
ayudarnos a pensar en ello
imagina que tenemos un cierto nivel de
producción imagina que nuestra
producción actual es de 1000 unidades
por día y nosotros sabemos cuál es el
producto marginal del trabajo y producto
marginal del capital
imagina que sabemos que nuestro producto
marginal del trabajo en esta producción
recuerda este cambia si tenemos
diferentes cantidades de producción es
decir si creemos más trabajo o más
capital así que imagina que nuestro
producto marginal del trabajo en este
nivel es de 90 unidades de producción
ahora otra forma de pensarlo es que por
cada unidad que incrementemos de trabajo
seremos capaces de producir 90 unidades
más de producción y digamos que el
precio del trabajo que ya vimos que es
el salario es igual a 10 pesos 10 pesos
por unidad de trabajo y digamos que el
producto marginal del capital déjame
cambiar a un color distinto es de 80
unidades de producción así que cada una
de las unidades que incrementemos en el
factor del capital seremos capaces de
producir 80 unidades más de producción y
digamos que el precio del capital que es
el alquiler es de 5 pesos 5 pesos por
unidad de capital
así que justo en este momento si
quisiéramos aumentar un peso sería más
racional gastarlo en el trabajo o en el
capital pausa el vídeo e intenta
encontrar la respuesta
bueno para pensar en que es más racional
tienes que pensar en cuál me da más por
mi dinero así que por cada peso cuántas
unidades de producción obtenemos del
trabajo y cuántas unidades de producción
obtenemos del capital
así que hagámoslo primero para el
trabajo si queremos saber cuántas
unidades de producción obtenemos de
nuestro dinero tenemos que dividir
nuestro producto marginal del trabajo
por el precio esto nos dirán nuestra
producción por peso
así que en esta situación tenemos 90
unidades de producción podemos decir
aplicaciones para ejemplificar un poco
la producción y vamos a dividirlo entre
10 así que esto será igual a 9 unidades
de producción por peso
así que esta es nuestra producción que
obtenemos por nuestro dinero ahora esto
es cuando aumentamos un peso en el
trabajo que sucede en el escenario del
capital bueno si realizamos la división
del producto marginal del capital entre
el precio del capital justo en este
momento recuerda que todo esto cambio a
lo largo del tiempo dependiendo de
nuestro nivel de producción y de
diferentes combinaciones serán 80
unidades de producción entre 5 pesos que
es lo mismo que 16 unidades de
producción por peso así que el cual de
los dos escenarios obtengo una mejor
inversión por mi dinero bueno justo en
este momento obtengo más al invertir en
capital ya que por cada peso que
incrementemos obtenemos 16 unidades de
producción será razonable para la
empresa si lo que quieres es maximizar
sus ganancias y reducir sus costos que
si tiene un peso extra
lo invierta en el capital y así tal vez
si lo pone en el capital y así obtiene
un poco más de producción entonces el
producto marginal del capital disminuye
un poco así que puedes imaginar que en
un punto estas dos cosas sean iguales y
en ese punto será indiferente para la
empresa elegir en cuál de los dos
escenarios invertir y tal vez en un
punto si ellos siguen agregando capital
puedan obtener una mejor inversión
si cambian y ahora invierten su dinero
en el trabajo de manera general una
empresa quería mantenerse invirtiendo en
uno o en otro hasta que estas dos cosas
son iguales la una a la otra así que
este es el panorama general puedes
pensar en el producto marginal del
factor entre el precio del factor y
compararlo con el producto marginal de
otros factores dividido entre el precio
de los otros factores y así elegir con
cuál obtienes una mejor inversión por tu
dinero
y será racional que ese es el factor a
invertir después llegarás de alguna
manera a una combinación eficiente al
llegar al punto en que es diferente
aquel donde los productos marginales
divididos entre los precios de los
diferentes factores son iguales entre sí
así que por ejemplo si te dijera que
estamos en un punto de producción
distinto y déjame separar a este otro
caso si estamos en un punto de
producción distinto donde nuestro
producto marginal del trabajo es igual a
10 aplicaciones y digamos que el precio
del trabajo es de 5 pesos y también
digamos que el precio del capital es de
10 pesos
entonces cuál tendría que ser nuestro
producto marginal de capital para que no
sea indiferente invertir entre el
trabajo y el capital pagos el vídeo e
intenta encontrar lo bueno para que no
sea indiferente invertir por aquí se
tiene que cumplir que el producto
marginal del trabajo entre el precio del
trabajo debe de ser igual al producto
marginal del capital entre el precio del
capital por lo tanto tenemos 10 entre 5
esto tiene que ser igual a nuestro
producto marginal del capital entre 10
10 en 35 son dos aplicaciones por peso y
si quiero dos aplicaciones por peso del
lado derecho éste tendría que ser 20 así
que en este punto nos es indiferente
entre invertir más en el trabajo o
capital porque en ambos casos por cada
peso que invierta si el producto
marginal del capital es de 20 seremos
capaces de producir dos aplicaciones por
peso al invertir en cuál
de los dos factores